The FBI
is searching President Biden's home
in Rehoboth Beach, Delaware, right now.
This is part of the ongoing investigation
into his handling of classified documents
Biden's attorney
put out a statement
saying that the search
was planned in advance
and that the president is cooperating.
Today's search
now makes it
the third known location
that federal agents have gone through
to look
for classified material at the properties
associated with President Biden.
Paula Reid,
she's joining us now from Washington.
With much more on this.
Paula, this all started really unfolding
just a little while ago.
What are you learning?
That's right.
Pool cameras actually
spotted vehicles
and what appeared to be federal agents
at the Rehoboth House.
And they were there because, Kate,
we have very much expected
that there would likely be an FBI
search of this property.
And as you noted,
this is being conducted in cooperation
with the president's attorneys
But to put this in context
and explain why we expected this.
Let's go back to the beginning
of this situation.
They uncovered
classified documents of the president's
former office back in November.
Several weeks
after that,
the president's own attorneys
decided out of an abundance of caution
to search his homes
in Wilmington, Delaware,
and this property in Rehoboth.
And they've said
that they did find
classified materials in Wilmington,
but they did not find any in Rehoboth.
And that subsequently became
the subject of a full blown
special counsel investigation.
And it was expected
that the FBI would want to go
and do its own searches.
Roughly two weeks ago,
of course,
the FBI did its own
search of the president's
Wilmington home,
and they uncovered
additional classified materials.
So we're expecting them
to show up in Rehoboth eventually.
That is today.
Of course, it's unclear, though,
how long this search will take.
Kate, the one in Wilmington
lasted roughly 13 hours.
But the big question
now is
whether they will find
any additional classified materials.
As of now,
our sources
say the total classified documents
that have been found will
that the former office
and at the Wilmington home
its characterized as dozens
known to date.
A big question,
will they find additional material?
And if so, will
they share that information
with the public?
There's been a real push and pull
in terms of transparency here.
They confirm this search
after we caught it on camera.
They have provided some details,
but most of the information
in this investigation
has come out through the press.
Yeah, that was
that was what I was going to ask you is
is is how quickly it's expected.
If there is something found,
what will when the public will learn?
We'll stand by
to stand by with you on that one.
Paula, thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Joining me now for more on
this is CNN legal analyst
Elliot Williams.
He's a former federal prosecutor.
Elliot, thanks for jumping on.
What do you make of the statement?
What do you make of this search?
Also, the statement
coming out from Biden's attorney
and it was.
Let me read just part of it,
because it's
what Paula was talking about.
She said the statement from Bob Barr was,
Under DOJ standard procedures
in the interest of operational security
and integrity,
it sought to do this work
without advance public notice.
And we agreed to cooperate.
What do you make of that?
You know, it's a little confusing
because it's the Justice Department
in Joe Biden's administration.
That's putting it out.
There are two different entities, right.
You have the Justice Department
that kind of operates independently.
And then you have the White House.
Now, look,
they have different interests here.
And the Justice Department's
key interest is maintaining
secrecy around its search.
And that's why,
you know,
they did not publicly announce it.
They just didn't
publicly announce the search and so on.
Right now, why they were able to come
to some
consent agreement to search their home,
is that the just
assume that they wouldn't
have gotten into a fight
over the documents with the fight.
But the Biden team.
I think the Justice
Department operated under the assumption
that they weren't expecting the president
or his aides to conceal
or hide or tamper with evidence.
That's why they came to some agreement
as to the search here.
But again,
it can be a little bit confusing
because, yes,
it is the Justice Department
yes, it's an independent entity,
but it's not the same thing
as the White House. Right.
Even though it's the same president.
And we know
to this point
that when Biden's team went through that
the home,
the Rehoboth home,
they said that they
did not find any
classified documents there.
If the FBI, through this search,
does find more documents
at this home at this point,
How problematic is that?
It's problematic
if the
FBI uncovers evidence
that there was intentional
taking or mishandling of documents
Look, Kate,
I had classified a top secret clearance
for many years.
It can be
easier than you think or hope
for classified documents.
To get out.
Most of the time
that it happens, it's inadvertent.
Someone takes a document out
accidentally or so on.
That may have been the case here.
Now, if the FBI uncovers evidence
that someone
and not just the president,
someone around the president on his team
voluntarily, knowingly took documents
away from the White House,
away from the scrutiny
of the National Records Administration.
Then, of course,
it should be alarming
because that can be a federal crime,
but most of the time
it simply would be an accident.
Classified documents
got out of where they should have been.
We also have reporting this morning
from Paul
Raitt as well that the special counsel,
Robert Hunter,
is now officially on the job.
And he obviously is a special counsel
who will be overseeing
this investigation into Biden's
handling of classified documents
watching from the outside
Elliot,
is there anything that we're going
to see that changes
now that he is running things?
I really don't think so, and
I really don't think
it should be the case.
Look, in
any well-functioning organization,
not even government
or the Justice Department
moving in and out, that the head
the principle
ought not to change the work
they were doing.
They were proceeding beforehand
with investigations and searches and
and going through evidence
even prior to Bob, her coming on now,
but having somebody as a
as a figurehead at the top can help
steer the ship
and make sure things are red,
are handled and proceeding effectively.
But the direction
shouldn't really change.
I mean,
I think that would actually be quite bad
for government.
Every time a new U.S.
attorney or a new special counsel came in
things fell apart
or changed quite dramatically.
So I'm not anticipating
things will be much different.
And look, at a minimum,
you can be certain
that the judge
is not going to start
talking
about the investigations
they're doing now
simply because someone else is coming in.
Their M.O., for better
or worse, is simply
to just keep their mouth shut.